they tell me you want to be a picture
maker what inspired you to cast David
Lynch in that part I had an actor in
mind I would mention who it is he's a
friend of mine who played John Ford and
then Tony Kutcher's husband Mark Harris
said what about David Lynch and Tony
called me so excited and said you know
what Mark just suggested who Mark just
suggested David Lynch and the light
bulbs went off the second I heard that
name I went oh my God Mark is so right
and so I called David that's right it's
everything word for word is what to the
best of my recollection happened to me
you know for a long time I thought that
was a horrible moment it happened to me
my hero gives me a bollocking in his
office get the [__]
having to live with that for years the
humiliation of what he did to me without
giving him the credit for what he was
actually trying to tell me which is look
at Art go to museums look at composition
look at color look at the Horizon he was
basically in two minutes and 40 seconds
giving me some of the greatest advice
anybody's ever given me